activity à un nouvel adhérent lagence
d'insertion professionnelle du
département accueille depuis hier
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines le territoire de saint quentin
c'est avec le territoire de la vallée de
la seine le territoire où il y à la fois
le plus grand nombre de bénéficiaires du
rsa mais aussi où il ya le plus grand
nombre d'entreprises
il ya dynamisme entrepreneurial qui est
très marquée une volonté de la
communauté d'agglomération d'accompagner
d'avoir une vraie compétence emploi de
la prendre à bras le corps
saint quentin en yvelines ses dix sept
mille entreprises et plus de 23 mille
postes non pourvus activités travaille
sur des remises à niveau et des
qualifications deux personnes éloignées
de l'emploi
j'ai entre conseil d'administration donc
déjà on va avoir un regard croisé de
notre territoire par rapport à ce que
eux ils amènent et puis nous qu'est ce
que nous pouvons apporter
on sait qu'on a des poches très complexe
au niveau des douze communes
on sait qu'on a des quartiers on a eu 8
pv sur notre territoire
sur ces 8 pb on sait bien qu'il ya des
actions et qui sont menées et plutôt
bien mené il y en a d'autres qui
demandent à être revitalisé dans ces
quartiers prioritaires 5% des actifs ont
un faible niveau de qualification
saint quentin en yvelines représente
plus de 26 % de l'emploi sur le
département